hey what's going on in spill burn is
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday November 26 2017 what's going on
how hmm what's up what's going on how
would you Thanksgiving how was your
Thanksgiving week oh it's over huh Jesus
Christ isn't it a great weekend it's
it's the best it's the if you don't
[ __ ] if you don't have to go anywhere
first of all if you don't have to go
anywhere
you know forget you got a wife and you
got a kid you don't have to go anywhere
people just come into your place it's
the best you know all your stuff is
there and the end people help clean up
well I had to buy little I had the
perfect Thanksgiving it was perfect and
I wanted oh I can't yell my daughter's
asleep [ __ ] taping this at night Sunday
night the potato pie sweet potato pie
killed I think I gave out some
misinformation I just bought the wrong
kind of sweet potato I bought a it was
the white one which I'm hurt I used for
other desserts but not for the pie but
people do actually use sweet potatoes
for sweet potato pie you can have also
actually use yams that's what I used
yams brown sugar cinnamon some nutmeg a
little bit of ginger some vanilla
whatever you know whole bunch of sugar
stirred the whole thing together and I
tell you I was sweating it okay [ __ ]
white guy making a sweet potato pie you
know what I mean I mean I'm living
dangerously here I thought I was going
to get booed like at the Apollo and
maybe people so I was psyched and then
my stuffing always kills my stuffing
always kills you know why because it
starts off with me melting us an entire
stick of butter in a pan that's where I
and I go from there
I don't care what you make and you can't
lose if you start by melting a stick of
butter in a pan you know these [ __ ]
lunatics nowadays did they will take
that oh can I pour
entire thing into my coffee I don't know
what's going on alright I have a lot of
stuff to promote I apologize for the AC
but it's as hot as [ __ ] in here I don't
know if you can hear that running over
my loud-ass voice here a bunch of stuff
the sixth annual Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit will be Tuesday February 20th
2018 at 7:00 p.m. people always go hey
man why is it always on Tuesday because
I got a bunch of comics working for free
that night
I can't haven't worked for free on a
Monday night money as in cha-ching not
isn't not Monday night not a Monday
night a money night alright it's gonna
be 7 p.m. at the city centre where we've
always had it
131 West 55th Street between 6th and 7th
avenues new york new york one double O 1
9 here's the lineup
Brendan Burns P Cory le Joe de raw Joey
Rosa's Sam J Robert Bobby Kelly there
Jessica Carson
[Music]
Sipho sounds and rich Voss with more
special guests to be announced ticket
prices are 75 bucks every seat and all
the money other than what we have to pay
to rent the [ __ ] place goes to goes
to his mom alright and his what would
have been his wife but he never got
around to marrying her anyway so there's
three ways to buy the tickets one you go
I may have all these all these links by
the way are up on my website all that
stuff ok and you can there's a number
you can call if you're sitting in your
cubicle right now two one two five eight
one one two one two at the theater and
at the box office you can go right to
131 West 55th Street all right it's
gonna be it's gonna be Tuesday February
20th 2018 at 7 p.m. and thank you to
everybody who's been coming for all of
these years because of you guys coming
out we've been able to keep Patrice's
name and his comedy alive and everybody
that you know that was in his life has
that he was helping to support and
everything as remain living comfortably
and been taken care of so it's one of
the you know things I'm most proud of as
far as all the things that you know I've
done in this business and I've watched
my friends do the fact that we all get
together and make sure that his mom and
his family are right rrright is uh is a
great thing so anyways on to the podcast
well if I'm gonna promote some stuff I
might as well promote a few other things
is uh speaking of comedians and I got to
get her on this benefit one of these
years a good friend of mine from way
back in the day became a filmmaker and
is now back is back to and stand-up Maya
did Giorgio absolutely [ __ ] hilarious
and I was talking to you tonight at the
Comedy Store I didn't realize I told her
you know Mike I really [ __ ] Irie
[ __ ] at my side big-time by playing
drums I think I already told you guys
that selves down there and I was just
telling her that you know how I messed
it up and then I I Reece crude it up by
playing drums she's like I didn't hate
play drums I used to play drums I
started talking to her mother used to be
this famous jazz singer and she played
at the Cotton Club and all this stuff
real jazz gigs and [ __ ] sit in with all
these legends started talking all this
drum stuff and she's a great comedian
anyway she's gonna be December 6 she's
going to be at levity live in Oxnard
California which is just outside of LA
it's a Wednesday night she's just
[ __ ] awesome so definitely check it
out I'll have the link up there for that
and lastly Judah Friedlander has a new
special on Netflix called
America is the greatest country in the
United States and me and Nia was sitting
in bed watching it really low on the
volume because you know a lovely
daughter sleeping in the other room and
just cracking up it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's brilliant I haven't seen him in so
long cuz he's a New York guy and I'm a
big LA phony here and I sent him a text
I told him how that guy is [ __ ]
brilliant man definitely check it out
it's so cool the way shot it it looks
like hell mostly this is black and white
probably did with a couple of iPhones
that she shot over the course of I don't
know how many months
of him screwing around doing bits
[ __ ] with the crowd you know and he
just would just would cut out just say
the cellar this date the cellar that
date all shot at the cellar it's it's
really it's really different it's
awesome Judah Friedlander America is the
greatest country in the United States
all right that's it let's get into the
end of the podcast here all right
let's dig in to the goddamn podcast in a
good way I did not do [ __ ] this weekend
I didn't do [ __ ]
other than this morning I woke up and I
got all my tax [ __ ] you know I do it at
the end of every month I just get all my
stupid receipts I organize them so I
don't have a [ __ ] Avalanche you know
April 14th to go through and throw up my
accountant and make his life miserable I
don't do that end of every month like a
little old lady you know I try to
balance the books I just do all of that
and then all I have to deal with is
whatever [ __ ] I did in the last 30
days rather than having to deal with 365
days it's the smartest [ __ ] thing
I've ever done because I mean back when
I used to live with Bobby Kelly right we
would sit and you know we would do like
a zillion spots a week you know on the
weekend you'd have like six seven eight
spots a night you know and I was working
uptown in downtown so I have all these
cab receipts and all of these receipts
from college gigs Club gigs bus tickets
train tickets all of this [ __ ] shoved in
like four different CVS bags by the end
of the year and you know we had to do
our own taxes back then or whatever and
we would just be sitting there with this
shitty [ __ ] coffee table without
giant plastic bags of receipts thank god
dude why did we do this why did we
[ __ ] why didn't we just along the way
at least just have an envelope that said
taxi receipts and I would try it every
year you know in a good year I'd make it
to March you know but I never made it
for the whole year most years I wouldn't
make it into February and I've just be
like F [ __ ] it but this year finally
years later 25 years in my career
finally you know I finally been doing it
and I kind of know where [ __ ] is like
major [ __ ] life insurance and stuff like
that I kind of know where it is like I I
know it's in one of two different places
I don't know which folder but um it's
really made my life a lot easier or
who's kidding who my wife if make her
life easier if I ever die it's like it's
either in that box or in that box and
it's sort of organized so anyways yeah I
did not do [ __ ] this weekend still
didn't drink I made it through I did not
drink so I'm up to 102 days by the time
you listen to some in triple digits over
there Mike [ __ ] got him by two
[ __ ] days two points yeah it wasn't
that it wasn't that bad no one was
really drinking so the temptation wasn't
really there and once the night was over
and my daughter was awesome and she
didn't cry nothing she's just like she's
so cool man she's so chill she's so you
know when people people actually say
that when she gets upset she looks like
me that's when she looks like me you
know what I mean and as much as that
hurts me to hear that I know it's true
so anyways I ended up I you know when
I'm home
I usually am the one that puts her to
bed I actually really enjoy doing it and
I have it down to a whole system and the
worst part is after they fall asleep in
your arms and you got to set them down
in the crib and then they cry for a
little bit and just walking away knowing
they're fine know when they just crying
they're okay that's the hard part but uh
I actually enjoy her falling asleep you
know laying on my arms so much that I
usually let her go for like an extra 20
minutes because I figure some day you
know she's gonna be like oh my god dad
god you're so embarrassing I'm really
trying to take all of this [ __ ] in so
anyways I put her to bed and I was
watching her on the little video and
then I went out on my back porch and I
smoked arguably the best cigar of the
year it was just it perfect you know it
was Thanksgiving it was an event so
there was no guilt of like look at me
smoking a cigar what am i some bum at a
track I said I smoked that it was
[ __ ] delicious delicious so couldn't
have gone any better and just when I
thought my weekend couldn't get all any
better I decided to watch every college
[ __ ] football game I could get my
eyeballs on and I did and ha did I see
some bright ones who please tell me
please tell me you son of a [ __ ] that
you [ __ ] sat down and you watched the
war on i-4 interstate 4 that runs
between the two underrated cities of
Tampa in Orlando Florida they don't get
any respect you know you got to be on
the East Coast and south of Lake
Okeechobee to get any respect in Florida
even then they still laugh at your and
if just if you're living in Fort
Lauderdale right you're up north on
Daytona Beach they all know you're doing
meth right you got to be down in Miami I
got a buddy my Forshaw he's gonna be on
my shows out there in Florida I'm doing
showing Hollywood Florida and in Orlando
going to a magic game in between
knocking off another team and he's a
Miami guy so I was thrashing him I was
making fun of Miami I was like dude
every guy in Miami is either a drug
dealer or a promoter or both I know that
isn't true but I just like trash in
places that I enjoy going to who doesn't
like Miami
anyways so interstate 4 runs between
Tampa and in Orlando and I watched that
game that game was [ __ ] it was like
watching a god this was like a video
game I can't even remember what the
[ __ ] score was it was like 40 to 35
and I got to tell you something with
some of the fastest most athletic to the
fastest most athletic teams I've seen in
a long time I don't know that I don't
know if then
division-one I don't know what their
deal is I don't know where they are but
I know this I've seen a lot of like good
players come out of South Florida
Central Florida so I don't know what
happened maybe they [ __ ] up in high
school you know punched a teacher I
don't know what happened but these guys
look like they could take on anybody
granted they're the same I don't [ __ ]
know it look great okay
everybody was flying around the field so
you know there was very few white people
out there you know what I'm saying here
so I'm watching this game it's 40 to 35
and Central Florida is trying to be the
first team ever in that conference or
whatever to ever to ever go winless and
within two years go undefeated so they
have a chance to do it they go up 40 to
like 35 or some [ __ ] and there's like a
minute a half left right what are you
gonna do you're gonna go into the
prevent you're gonna give up the whole
the first [ __ ] 80 yards and then
you're gonna go into then you're gonna
start finally playing defense right you
know I hate the [ __ ] prevent defense
well guess guess what Central Florida
does evidently they didn't go into the
prevent because inexplicably somehow
this [ __ ] guy got behind their
defense with a minute and a half left
for like a 70 80 yard touchdown which by
the way it was like a 20-yard pass and
then he just ran 50 yards so I
immediately tweet in all caps how the
[ __ ] do you let that happen as I'm
finishing the tweet and hitting send
it's now tied 42 42 South Florida kicks
the [ __ ] ball off a stunned stadium
of Central Florida fans are watching
going can we at least get down to field
goal position that we just [ __ ] blow
our whole season the [ __ ] do it in
Central Florida catches the ball that
kickoff and ran the [ __ ] thing back
so then I had the tweet again how the
[ __ ] do you let that happen so now I was
like 49-42 I'm sure I got the score
wrong was they both in the 40s and then
I'm sitting there going love those two
plays was so [ __ ] up did easily
Central Florida could run this [ __ ]
ball back a South Florida should say
they didn't and and the game ended but
Jesus Christ one
entertaining game and then the next day
I watched Michigan Ohio State and then I
watched the Iron Bowl and watched Auburn
beat Alabama and watching Michigan
versus Ohio State I've come to the
conclusion that I [ __ ] hate
quarterbacks who run I hate a running
quarterback I just can't [ __ ] stand
it you know I don't think it should be
legal for a quarterback to run all right
or if you run then you get treated like
a running back this whole [ __ ] thing
that you can wait till everybody
everybody covers they called the right
defense nobody's open and then you can
just take off running when nobody's
[ __ ] looking that's all well and good
but you should get stuck but it's all
like he gave himself up he threw himself
on the ground leave him alone [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you if you're gonna take off
running you should get stuck either that
I'll keep you [ __ ] [ __ ] running
around ass behind the goddamn line it's
[ __ ] driving me crazy I'm a Michigan
fan so I'm watching that [ __ ] and
Michigan's [ __ ] defense was lights out
and that [ __ ] [ __ ]
kept running eight yards nine yards guy
couldn't complete a pass he couldn't
feel pressure but he could [ __ ] run
and then when he ran there to be like oh
he's a quarterback if I was coaching for
the other team I'd be like listen hit
the [ __ ] guy take the take the
penalty I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not saying deliberately energy him
but [ __ ] hit him I don't care now it
drives me up it drives me up the
congratulations to a house I don't hate
how I have state whatever I'm just more
of a Michigan fan and Michigan's just in
a weird year I don't know what their
deal is I mean they they don't have a
bear quarterback
I hate trashing college players cuz
they're still kids or whatever but he
could have had a better game he's a
little amped up in the beginning and I
don't know what happened on that last
play I think miscommunication maybe the
guy broke off the pattern or whatever
because it will you just [ __ ] threw
to the guy but Jim Harbaugh oh and three
oh and three against Ohio State you're
telling me his wife had a good [ __ ]
weekend he comes home this [ __ ] Woody
Hayes glasses all steamed up but Jesus
Christ a defense Michigan's defense was
great and how about that kid that came
in after uh uh how state's quarterback
went down he played great and he could
throw the ball he could throw the ball
and run so maybe they got a future with
him I have no idea and then I you know I
got a buddy j-law head is a big Ohio
State guy so he's always arguing the
case as - Wow how Iowa State should be
in the [ __ ] playoff every he did it to
me last year [ __ ] talking to me he
tried to explain to me how a high o
state should be in in the the the the
fourteen playoff and it's like to think
loss to Penn State Penn State won the
Big Ten championship Penn State doesn't
make it in but Ohio State does he goes
yeah I'll tell you why strength of
schedule
he [ __ ] does all the [ __ ] math and
then what happens they play Clemson and
they get the old right there Fred Wright
31 to nothing you know somebody else
should have been in there so I love Jay
he was doing that to me again the other
day via text and I'm just laughs at
thinking like dude he's always talking
about how Alabama stinks and there's
nobody [ __ ] in the SEC it's like the
big 10 sucks the big 10 still sucks
it's not that good Penn State was
overrated
they were overrated they lost to a house
stayed there was a huge [ __ ] win and
then the very next week what happened
Iowa State beats Penn State the next
[ __ ] week Penn State loses to
Michigan State and Ohio State gets
[ __ ] raped raped by [ __ ] Iowa so I
don't know he's always talking about how
weak the SEC is it's like you get the
[ __ ] out of here look at the big tent
Jesus Christ how many teams you got
laying down every week
Rutgers Indiana Purdue northwestern a
[ __ ] Minnesota I hate to say Nebraska
but they're they're no good that's six
[ __ ] teams right then Michigan State
is always half-ass
oh man I'm gonna get some [ __ ] mail
this week and Michigan isn't that good
they're still trying to put it together
so who the [ __ ] are you playing out
there I don't get it
you know look at [ __ ] Auburn Auburn
beat Georgia when Georgia was number one
and now they beat Alabama when Alabama
was number one
so Alabama's number one they take a loss
in the last game of the season so now at
they out the whole [ __ ] thing is just
it's just a symptom of the game you
can't have the March Madness because
everybody would be getting concussions
and ruining million-dollar [ __ ]
careers so this is the best system we
got so I guess it creates arguing but I
got to tell you it what a [ __ ] week
but just the college football was
[ __ ] amazing then I watched a little
bit and I never watched pac-12 I watched
look at Washington Washington State
Jesus Christ a bunch of players on those
teams too and for some reason my wife
just let me do it you know it's funny
you know we actually we went out
shopping after the Michigan [ __ ] Ohio
State game and I was so [ __ ] pissed
I'm so [ __ ] pissed because I just
felt like Michigan they had a better
defense they should have won and they
just kept you in that little [ __ ] he
[ __ ] eight yard scamper for a first
down to keep the [ __ ] drive alive was
driving me crazy
and then I don't know I just went out I
just like you know I don't know why I
get that into games but you know my wife
could sense it I just said yeah listen I
just [ __ ] you know I just watched a
game I did not like the outcome right
that's just because Jesus Christ all
right so then we're walking around okay
we're with all these people like you
know Christmas shopping and [ __ ] and you
know there was this a group of [ __ ]
Asian people I don't know I don't know
they will for whatever reason we're
walking down the sidewalk like 17 people
across and we were behind him and they
were walking like half a mile an hour I
don't know if they just got done eating
Thanksgiving dinner I don't know what it
was but I was having what this comic I
used to know John Bush used to call it
walk rage
instead a road-rage used to do this
great bit about having walk rage in New
York City and I was just sitting there
like how the [ __ ] do you not I mean I
get it there's a whole family there with
their grandparents you know an agent
people respect their elders
they're not like Americans but we would
have thrown those old people in the home
and we would have picked up the pace
when we walk down the street so I was
trying to respect their culture but at
the end of the day I'm selfish so I was
just like what the [ __ ] we finally get
by him and my daughter didn't want to be
in the [ __ ] stroller so I got her out
and I'm caring and my ribs are [ __ ]
talking to me and one of my shoulders is
[ __ ] out I'm a mess right I'm like you
know I'm like a [ __ ] journeyman
quarterback right now I'm like Steve
Grogan at the end of his career
I should have been walking around like
that [ __ ] neck brace so I'm already
grumpy and then this lady's kid is
having a [ __ ] temper tantrum and
we're stopped at the red light waiting
to walk across the street and this kid
is hitting this [ __ ] note that is
making my ears which are jumped from
playing drums vibrate in this painful
way that's making my teeth hurt so Nia
goes hey we can cross up here and right
as I do that the [ __ ] woman with the
screaming kid heard it too and started
following me and she as they say in
aviation she was a beam my [ __ ] left
eardrum which means just right alongside
of it and I just I was walking away and
I couldn't see she was right but I
couldn't understand why it wasn't
getting quieter and that she came I
turned around I saw that she was
following us up there and I just I I
snapped I snapped I was under my breath
going jesus [ __ ] christ can you just
[ __ ] get that [ __ ] kid the [ __ ]
away from me I was gonna near stop just
let him go past jesus [ __ ] it was
completely irrational I was a hundred
percent wrong but it was just all those
things building up and like I said I
already walk around it a six so it's
very easy for me to get back up to a
tent so Nia stopped talking to me
and then I was like guy here we go you
know and then I was a baby about it I'm
like oh really really a shot of a
football game I'm driving over here we
just bought this I did do this I took
the [ __ ] garbage out just cuz I drop
a bunch of f-bombs in public about some
other woman's crying kid you know I did
the dishes that's not a push that's not
a wash you know I thought like I thought
that all balanced it out so you know I
put up a good fight on the ride home and
then I find just admit I get right
you're right I'm just arguing because I
know you're right and I'm embarrassed I
shouldn't have done that
what are you what are you gonna do I
mean they wrote a song about me a long
time ago how I'm not a perfect person
yeah I don't know why I did it
you know something I would go to [ __ ]
anger management but I just don't feel
like telling my stories all over again
I've already gone to therapy I just
don't you know gonna retell these
[ __ ] things you know gonna reboot it
like [ __ ] Full House on Netflix she's
got to have it
they just keep rebooting [ __ ] doing the
same [ __ ] over again I'm gonna do that
tell these [ __ ] stories all over I'm
sick of my stories that was part of my
argument too I was just like you know
Mia this is this is you know something
this is who I am this is what I do okay
I am really good at being a comedian I
make a great living we have a great life
but every once in a while I'm gonna drop
a bunch of f-bombs because of babies
crying okay
that's why and you know some I usually
babies crying usually makes me laugh
because I'm usually on a plane when they
start crying and they're expressing
exactly what I'm feeling and it's just
like it's like a great comedy it's just
like dude I hear ya that's exactly what
the [ __ ] I'm feeling I don't know just
all built a house date beat Michigan
then there was the Hands Across America
Asian family that I couldn't get around
and it was like 20 thousand other
[ __ ] things going on - it was just
like it was a [ __ ] show and I [ __ ]
hate Christmas shopping but by the way
dude I've crushed it this year all my
nieces and nephews all have presents
they're all wrapped and I'm mailing them
out to respective families this week
okay hey Santa go [ __ ] yourself
I beat you by four weeks grand you have
to deliver it to the whole world but you
know whatever whatever Santa's the
number one seed I'm like a sixteenth
seed I got into the dance cell no but
yeah sixteenth seed in the bracket
that's right right all right anyways I
don't what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
let's do please please buy tickets to
the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit so we
can do this again we have some surprise
guests hopefully I'm reaching out to
some big names nudge nudge wink wink all
right me undies everybody all right um
all right oh [ __ ] here I got I guess I
got a singer sample do do do me undies
me undies
losing my [ __ ] over a crying baby but do
do do me undies biondi's yeah why didn't
you join the Navy because I'm scared of
the [ __ ] ocean but I would have
fought a shark not to listen to that
[ __ ] baby sorry I don't know I'm all
over the map right every every year
millions people receive that was it yeah
I just I [ __ ] snapped I don't always
know when me is not going to talk to me
anymore because not only does she not
talk to him anymore she gets this look
on her face so I started looking at the
side of her face and I'm just like oh
that's that look I know that look
I know what she still when she's
rewinding 20 years of her life going how
the [ __ ] did I end up with this guy all
right me undies every year millions of
people received the least liked gift of
all time underwear but we still give it
up to our family are in our loved ones
who just don't want it but may by the
way what is that [ __ ] underwear that
they do that they sell oh [ __ ] look
who's here
oh come on on the podcast I was talking
about how when I got mad at the baby
oh Jesus the look just came right back
huh you're still shaking your head over
that yeah she didn't hear me I heard you
sorry I heard you didn't like it you
wanted can you sing the me undies jingle
about what an [ __ ] I am but oh do to
me and ease me on DS he's a [ __ ] news
me Ani yes Yanni's what have you got to
lose what are you doing you doing this
do doopy doopy it's me on these me
undies no more sweaty balls yeah you got
that part
oh whatever yeah alright okay every year
millions of people what's what the ABC
does it gross you out that guy's
underwear commercial with it like no
pinch no stink no something or other and
it's always some fat redneck dude like I
don't want to know that yet Tate smells
like deer urine cuz you just got back
from the forest or whatever those
[ __ ] people do I mean it's for its
for a practical purpose it's not
supposed to be sexy it's not supposed to
be inviting or whatever it seems to be
like for fat white guys it's definitely
for white guys fat white guys I mean
they join the guys fact he's not even
husky yeah he's all thick he's fat yeah
I guess he's fat you want that crawling
on top of you I don't mind a husky fella
really all right
we must not like how I'm looking because
I'm crushing it lately
I am wafer thin you not to get too
skinny you should still have a little
you know not something to hold on cuz
that's a week yeah that is weird
but like don't get so like you get you
just get so and you really do get
manorexic like you get so like obsessed
no I don't yeah this is the [ __ ]
weight I was when I came into this
business and people weren't like oh my
god your man or exes that you what it is
is you get used to what I look like
after eating drinking a thousand [ __ ]
glasses of booze and pizza
that's all beer and pizza then if I
actually get into the weight that I'm
supposed to be you like how my god you
look sick my heart is psyched right now
I never said you look sick you said I
look like I have AIDS don't you bill
that's not even funny I would never say
that don't tell people I said that on
the pot you said it and you made a sign
and you held it up in the kitchen
no I did not see no what did you say it
no way I'm sorry
you said you want do you want some
Rolaids yeah not not those are those
antacids you didn't you said yeah these
biondi's no more blood disease all right
but maybe it's not the that underwear is
the problem it's the kind of underwear
let me tell you about my undies it's the
only underwear this makes for an amazing
gift soft flexible waistband alright me
undies I love you guys but who's kidding
who this is a stocking stuffer don't
lead with this okay this this this gift
is not bad and clean up this is just a
nice little soft landing I got you the
[ __ ] thing you wanted and here you go
his Amy all I'm gonna get you for
Christmas is me undies how you feel
about that
I would love some me undies no that's
all you're getting no I want more than
that why thank you and when I give you
underwear where should I put it and it's
a stocking stuffer sorry I'm too close
to the mic here it's three mm-hmm why
don't you get a microphone I just so you
won't be off mic so people can hear you
and I can also get through the people
can hear me just fine like people tweet
me that that they can hear me while
you're sitting there be like good are
you you're used to screaming into a
microphone which is because the
microphone is meant to amplify your
voice it's meant to carry you like like
yeah yeah I'm criticizing you
yeah I'm threatening you yeah I'm
threatening you good sit down here then
all right
well you got to get another microphone
the microphones in the other room
alright did you know me undies is three
times softer than cotton that's very
soft isn't it is that horse muzzle soft
my undies that's my favorite touch like
that yeah I don't know what you call it
what do you call it when you have a
favorite thing that you like to touch if
you said this on our first date there
wouldn't have been a second date oh
that's my it's my favorite touch what do
you call it when there's a thing you
like to touch like my favorite things
other than our baby's beautiful face oh
good the undies made underwear the
perfect gift that everyone is going to
love you for it's a goddamn holiday
miracle this year they've had that read
the copy this year give the gift of me
undies this holiday season to get your
exclusive 20% off the softer side to
wearing socks you'll ever wear free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed go to the undies
talk comm slash bird that's me undies
comm slash burp all right dollish I told
you a joke bartnick told me about that
homeless guy ran into a Milwaukee no he
came up to me the homeless guy this is
his joke to make you laugh to give him
money he came up to me goes hey did you
hear Bob Barker died and Joe goes what
he goes yeah he got hit by a new car so
stupid Joe laughter they all right he's
a buck
all right Dollar Shave Club everybody
Dollar Shave Club ships amazing razors
for a few bucks what you might not eat
dub Bob Barker's not dead right I don't
know I hope not and I really hope he
wasn't hit by a car well he definitely
wasn't hit by a car TMZ would have been
over there telling you reading the
[ __ ] VIN number Dollar Shave Club
ships amazing raises for a few bucks
what you might not know is that Dollar
Shave Club also has products for pretty
much everything else you need in the
bathroom man body wash shampoo hair gel
pube clippers lip balm everything
have pube clippers now you don't have to
step foot you could shave your pubes
with their razors I mean no one's
telling you not to no one's telling you
to either certainly not here on the
podcast I know that head moves for to go
around chin I don't know if you want to
[ __ ] with your junk start the year off
right
shave your shaft and your balls you
heard of here don't do that we do not
condone that jokes made on the podcast
are not to be taken seriously you know
the illiterate reader here all right now
you don't have to step foot in a store
to get high-quality shave and grooming
products dollar shave club delivers them
right to your door
just like their razors everything is
super high-quality and you will and
we'll have you looking and feeling
amazing from premium ingredients to
sophisticated since Dollar Shave Club is
changing the game if you're sick of the
nonsense at the store now's the time to
try out Dollar Shave Club for a limited
time Dollar Shave Club is basically
giving away their [ __ ] shower shave
starter set to new members for only $5
this starter set features the exclusive
executive razor and the three trial size
versions of their most popular products
to help you stay so fresh it's so clean
and your first box you receive this
shave butter body wash in one way
Chili's butt wipes
there's no way to wipe your ass in one
wipe that just isn't ok there is I don't
have to wipe your whole yeah just one
wipe and you're good with that you're
confident to pull up your underwear and
your drawers and just walk around not
thinking you get to be a little yeah you
should
one white Charlie's how about [ __ ]
for wipe Eddie's a little swirl there
you doing [ __ ] jokes here you also
receive their executive razor which
includes their premium weighty handles
in a focused set of cartridges after the
first box replacement cartridges are
sent for only a few bucks a month this
offer is exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com slash / that stylist
shave club.com / / and if you want to
get a great gift give them Dollar Shave
Club they got super simple gift
memberships at at a gift and a gift
cards [ __ ] Dollar Shave club's high
quality products will have you covered
from face cheeks to butt cheeks there's
no better time to try the club and
mercifully just about like the whole
shaving thing especially for Dollar
Shave Club are these real razors or they
like Gillette style I mean why wouldn't
they be real razors and why did you just
name their competition in the middle of
it first of all this coca-cola does it
taste like Pepsi no it's a toy Mia it
doesn't even do the job it's just
they're just doing this for fun for fun
and then you you open the you open this
it's not a safety razor that's what I
mean it's like it's like the one I
shaved my head with for the safety razor
yeah these people have been advertising
for a long time please don't ruin this
for me I've lost so much advertising on
this can we just don't poke this the
Golden Goose hear them and stamps calm
these gay rider die they don't give a
[ __ ] what I say me undies
I love Dollar Shave Club I love stamps I
love I love them all you love Oh zip
all right stamps.com
with the holiday almost here it is it
just was Thursday right Thanksgiving
that's a holiday it's time to go
Santa's at the mall who has time to go
to the post office
it'll be busy with people sending
holiday cards and gifts so do what we do
use stamps calm instead I'm so stupid I
never thought to do this I only do with
my posters why don't I send out all
those gifts using stamps calm brings all
the services of the US Postal Service
right to your fingertips buy in print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer then the mailman
picks it up stamps calm makes it easy
they'll send you a digital scale
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps calm will even help you decide
that the best class of mail every to
help you decide the best class of mail
every time print postage any day any
time stance now calm is always open I
use stamps calm whenever I send out my
posters I'm a [ __ ] if I can figure it
out so can you and right now you too can
enjoy the stamp stock comps service with
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus postage and a digital
scale without long term commitments go
to stamps calm click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
bur that stamps calm enter Barbie you
are are alright with that let's read
some of the some of the letters from my
listeners he if I'm listening is baggy
sharing I'm reading all of these I read
all of them not 20 minutes hey what's
your rush okay relax sit down take it
easy ok ok ok alright progressive rock
oh by the way [ __ ] you Australia yes
[ __ ] that whole country for not telling
me about the wonderful Australian group
see what I did there I got everybody
down there whatever I what's this
[ __ ] [ __ ] shrimp on the barbie how
do they talk down there
I know it is it's also a country and
it's an island they don't know what they
want to be how the [ __ ] do you have up
all these weeks I've been asking you for
a great [ __ ] noob and my drum teacher
just talking about this band carnival
sound awake I listen to that album jesus
[ __ ] christ what a band there are may
I cannot recommend that's that's the one
I don't know any of their other albums
that's the one I got sound awake their
[ __ ] drummer I got to get the guy's
name right now what is his name
I bet I've been so listening to that
album I didn't even look up the
drummer's name it's [ __ ] amazing
where was it okay what are you doing you
why are women so [ __ ] nosy that is so
creepy what was I looking up [ __ ] with a
K alright carnival drummer that's how
it's spelled
Steve Judd Jesus Christ that guy's a
beast incredible incredible top to
bottom everybody in that band singer
guitar play a bass player at the whole
[ __ ] thing the drummer unbelievable
please download that listen to it tell
me how much you love it Australia well
you got it you got any more bands like
that or what do you hold now for every
week I'm [ __ ] sitting here like a
little little kid you know on Christmas
but no presents just asking them maybe
they don't tell me anything I go down
liked I go all the way out to Perth what
thanks do I get yeah [ __ ] album came
out in 2010 why they treat me like that
now why alright anyways anyways shout
out to little creatures beer can'twe
progressive rock I know you don't give a
[ __ ] about that I'll read that more
alright Emily linden tweets you know
what I do this one
I don't know all right what who was
Emily Linda I didn't know whose house
she was either she's somebody on the
Twittersphere she's uh she's got um
social media she tweeted some [ __ ] about
I don't know some [ __ ] I don't know hey
there Billy fair trail I imagine you've
been sent this article many times over
the last week I had here's an excerpt
from an article about what the writer
for Teen Vogue tweeted here's an
unpopular opinion I'm not actually all
that concerned about innocent men losing
their jobs over false sexual assault /
harassment allegations the benefit of
all of us getting to finally tell the
truth plus the impact on victims far
Capitals far outweighs the loss of any
one man's reputation she said adding if
some innocent men's reputation have to
take a hit in the process of undoing the
patriarchy that is the price I am
absolutely willing to pay it's hilarious
you're not paying a price in that that
gettig innocent guy is the most cognate
because I didn't say the word so stupid
critique of Lyndon came from CNN anchor
Jake Tapper the lead host tweeted Willis
to CNN there's bad as Fox News I'm
guessing you didn't get a good grade for
your seventh grade book report on To
Kill a Mockingbird referencing the
classic novel that features the trial of
a black man falsely accused of rape in
the 1930s Alabama you said if some
innocent men's reputation have to take a
hit in the process of undoing the
patriarchy that is a price I am
absolutely willing to pay that's immoral
tapper wrote and it's not a price you
would be paying by the way it would be
an innocent innocent men doing that all
right he said my wife is back to the guy
writing my wife is black and she has a
cousin who served six months in jail for
being falsely accused of rape he lost
his academic scholars academic not
sports scholarship and has been having
trouble getting his life back on track
since having his conviction overturned
from being physically and emotionally
abused in
jail she said that is she ever wait she
said that if she ever saw this woman in
public she and I quote slapped the [ __ ]
out of that irresponsible [ __ ] bill I've
never heard of use the c-word or even
threatening violence against anyone it's
like that line now you just go in a
completely different direction that line
from Batman The Dark Knight you either
die a hero or live long enough to see
yourself become the villain all right
you're all over the place I don't know
what's going on here what do I think
that I think that's the tweets of
somebody young and then also its kind of
seems that's a little WWE wrestling
grandstanding knowing there's no way you
write that not knowing you know it's
like watching now notorious guy there
won't be MMA guy the crazy [ __ ] he says
he knows what he's doing yeah and then
ever he's like he's too cocky I want to
watch him lose and then then he wins and
he gets your money I think that that's
what I think that's all this is
that's pretty Webb anism yeah I mean
that's pretty much this is why people
don't like being labeled a feminist
because of stuff like that
elaborate no that's all I'm gonna say
about it I feel like nobody white and
those are you talking about but
everybody black right now does oh my god
was that shade and my woke yeah I mean
that's just one of those I don't know
what do you know what that's how she
feels that's how she feels what am I
suppose I'm I supposed to actually like
like respond to that like that's like
some sort of rational human being what
do you what this person foaming at the
mouth I don't know they remind me of
myself
was completely yeah yeah can I make this
any more easier for you yeah I love how
you you only wanted to [ __ ] and respond
to the ones that were easy and I want to
give you a chance to respond you're like
you're like Bill Belichick Lionel she's
a you know that's why feminism I know so
you know but I have but I can elaborate
it can get into these next elaborate I
don't want to I don't want to know why I
don't know maybe I am being a wuss but I
just
yeah it's that's I don't know there's
really no other way for me to explain it
than to say that that's it's just you
it's a level of not night not they're
not naive they're not like maybe just in
a bubble or something just like so
sheltered sheltered so it's like all
they can focus on is like the one thing
you know what I mean and they just can't
quite grasp well that's that joke I do
in my act when like when I listen to
feminists like it's hard for me to
listen to white women in the United
States of America complaining like going
you know you know what it's like to be
me slightly less awesome than what my
life is like if you look at the big
picture I'm sure there seems to be a
giant gap between me and you but if you
look at everybody else's situation we're
rad we're kind of sitting on the same
stone here so why don't you buy a run
around a lady all right I'm sorry am i a
rebound chump is this good Nia is this
in your wheelhouse yeah I think so
keep going you'd be a great president is
what presidents do now they like they
basically I don't like the way that guy
asks questions let's bring this person
in no I I do have to have time for all
these you don't have time I mean okay
all right am i a rebound chump dear
Billy 4head you saying all this funny
[ __ ] off the mic I'm telling you but
they they say and they can hear you I
said probably at the time yeah the time
he's gone or a huge fan of your comedy
and podcast did you hear that Nia huge
fan of my comedy huge huge huge greatest
greatest comedian ever gonna do stand-up
on a golf course with my own name
attached
what Donald Trump would think of your
podcast I mean I don't care what he
thinks about anything but I wonder what
he would think about your podcast as far
as what I don't know like do you think
he would be into it or not even though
you trash him you trash everybody I
think he's busy running the country I
don't he's [ __ ] clearly not by the
way that he tweets he's clearly not that
[ __ ] busy he's not that busy who has
time to tweet the petty [ __ ] that he
does he's got that's what's great about
Twitter it takes to second wing all the
the actual stuff he's just sitting there
like you know the what do you call it
the spot like I don't know I don't know
what the [ __ ] he's just he's working
he's working Obama works
Bill Clinton worked yeah yeah that's a
guy who worked it I can't even speak
straight anyway come on am i a rebound
Trump its Trump really that bad dear
Billy for head side just like getting
Mia going I just like it a good really I
mean I don't know you got to give the
guy a chance the worst because it was
hot as [ __ ] in here you're usually the
one who runs hot I know I know I know am
i a rebound chump yeah shut the [ __ ]
thing off Jesus Christ this is why it
takes forever you the second you bring a
woman into your [ __ ] thing like if
you're gonna leave the house everything
has to be perfect
my feet are together rub them together
like issue you're always are are we
ready okay yes huge fan of your comedy
in the podcast hearing you shoot the
[ __ ] every week obviously makes me laugh
but also gives me insight and other
things anyways it's hard to find love
alright I get too many compliments thank
you I met this girl
buddhu dude who's probably the best
looking chick I've ever been with and
her personality so far looks just as
good we are both in college in
neighboring states but we hang out a
couple times a week on average things
have been going great for the past two
we have traveled around her state and
she has shown me places I have never
seen I did not expect anything to bloom
like it has and was originally content
with just being friends who [ __ ]
however after getting to know her better
she definitely seems like someone I
could stick around with for a while and
maybe even date what are you guys doing
now sightseeing no just hanging out okay
sorry
well if I have to read and also listen
to what I'm saying liking I can't do
that the only thing is the only thing
she has and the only thing yeah
the only things she has an ex who I
suspect she's still hoping will come
back
all right incident one on our second
date quote she rented a movie on Ana's
Amazon on her ex's account and got a
text of him asking what that was about
what is she doing you know good and
goddamn well you can't order on your
ex's account like they're gonna they're
still paying for that
Lucy's a little minx e this one she
seemed delighted that he was forced to
communicate with her and she wired him
money and said sorry incident number two
so he's obviously broken up with her
right okay incident number two she
originally stated that they broke up
back in February but one night she let
it slip that they had actually broken up
in August just a couple months ago I
acted like I didn't notice after banging
one night she starts joking about having
a baby and what features it would have I
have brown hair as does she and she
remedy says the baby could be blonde the
color of her ex's hair she then went on
to say your ex's name was one of her
favorite names for a boy Jesus Christ do
this is good this is like getting
ridiculous if when I'm starting to not
believe it thankfully she waited until I
finished or my dick and balls would have
deflated immediately during all this
baby /x talk incident number four Jesus
Christ buddy exhibit 1995 she still uses
her ex's Amazon Prime account to watch
movies but on two occasions she began
snooping through his order history right
in front of me either unaware of how
off-putting that is are simply not
giving a [ __ ] disrespectful to myself
and the ex in my opinion another
confusing twist is that she gets pissed
off and said if I referred to her is my
friend we're not in an official
relationship so this would suggest that
she is at least kind of interested but
with all this stuff going on about her
ex I think she might just like the
attention I provide and think she may be
stringing me along she is also randomly
accused me of using her for attention
and having other hoes neither of which
are true sorry for this long email it's
hard to put all this [ __ ] into words
which you are great at if the Leahy's in
the emotional side of this may be me
just reading what you just wrote out
loud will be enough if the lovely nia is
nearby I would love to hear her take as
well thanks and go for a jog once in a
while all right what do you got it yeah
this girl is [ __ ] crazy and she's not
over her ex and she is using you to get
jealous and if you don't mind banging
her because she's hot and all that and
letting it go then fine but if you're
starting to catch feelings I would bail
Wow he said that nice and quick I agree
with all of that I concur that's exactly
it if you could somehow not get
emotionally tied to her and just keep
banging her she is incredibly
disrespectful she does not care about
you at all
the things that she is saying and doing
in front of you is so ridiculous like
how are you gonna lie in bed with
someone and be like you know when I have
a baby like I end up this you know Caleb
because this is also
some white girl [ __ ] like Caleb I just
feel like would be the perfect name for
a boy and he's just sitting there like
are you serious like your ex-wife
yeah you know what this could be a great
dude he should be he should just I don't
know I think you should just say some
just think listen you've but this is one
of these people that it doesn't even say
anything because it's not gonna they're
not gonna sit there and be like wow I
guess you're right I really shouldn't
have done that just person is not gonna
give a [ __ ] so whatever man you get to
paying a hot chick and she's not over
the other guys who gives a [ __ ] thank
God you didn't marry her though dude and
thank God that other guy broke up with
her because she seems I don't granted
it's all you you to be mad at him when
he called when he introduces her as a
friend she has the [ __ ] nerve to get
mad after all that craziness that she's
putting him through uh-huh get out of
here this is classic hot chick crazy hot
chick behavior though this is classic
crazy that I told that dick I'm told I
think I told her two weeks ago that hot
chick I met at the gym and she kept you
know giving me a number and she wanted
to go out and I kept trying to get her
out but she wouldn't go out with me and
then finally she picks a date yeah come
over we can hang on Saturday and she
goes oh I'm moving can you she wanted me
to help her move and I just bursted out
laughing I'm gonna [ __ ] doing that
and she had some other chump who came
over there to who's gonna be the two of
us standing there like maybe if I pick
up something heavier it [ __ ] me I was
just like he's all yours buddy yeah but
that's incredibly rude yeah that's the
thing that's why that right there that
statement I can't knock the hustle but
that's incredibly rude that's why oh you
just be funny honestly that's that's why
I get all that that that male feminism
horseshit were they just sitting there
drinking the [ __ ] kool-aid like women
just you know there aren't as many just
as many [ __ ] absolute sociopath
psychos that have vaginas out there is
it's there just saying what they think
women want to hear and so Jesus Dan you
just really get cut to the chase so cut
to the chase here
trying to do an hour here you just
[ __ ] bing-bang-boom done
all right girlfriend wants plastic
surgery how do you feel about that title
Nia is this an easy enough class for you
yes I'm excited to hear this hello bill
big fan of your work could use some lady
advice here all right is this a lady no
some lady advice sorry my girlfriend has
been dropping hints for months months
now about getting plastic surgery nose
in boob job
bump bump a bomb boo
Wow well she looks perfect in my eyes
she said she hates her nerd Jim nose in
her tiny tits she has big she has big be
size Cup she has a piece size Cup sorry
that's me bra whatever the [ __ ] is
called which like ehehe not which whi CH
this is which on a broom which is all I
need I tried to ignore it for as long as
I could now she says she wants it for
Christmas too fake press one nose job
saw that was a good show can you shoot
me sorry and a bag of [ __ ] tampons on
the third day of Christmas my true love
gave to me three [ __ ] remove no moles
to boob jobs one bleach tassel and a bag
of Botox in a pear tree come on let's do
the plastic surgery on the fourth day of
Christmas my true love gave to me for
corrected hammertoes three removed no
moles to fake tits and a bleached
[ __ ] and in a pear tree that I can't
[ __ ] do it
[Applause]
five inches off my [ __ ] lips they
hugged on too far one bleach [ __ ] -
it's a Botox in a pear tree Nick can you
get me
hair plugs for Christmas on the twelfth
day of Christmas my true love gave to me
what would you get 12 things of 12
stretch marks removed 11 to 2 fees
bleached
7 eyebrow hairs plucked I don't know
what to say Nick can you get me hair
plugs for Christmas but here's the thing
I just want them right down the center
of my head I want to get I want to grow
mohawk ok anyways well she looks perfect
she says okay she's Bubba but but now
she's saying she wants it for Christmas
or she's anti-semitic oh yeah maybe she
goes again like he got undergrad when I
am Juno's you know they say like well my
pitch to hang outside of my overalls you
know what so I know it's so stupid act
like only only southern white people are
racist how all right now she's saying
she wants for Christmas I told her she's
perfect the way she is I love you just
the way you are but she has low
self-esteem which which dude is WH IC H
not which W TCH W is whi t know it's WH
IC H or witc which is probably why she
uses why she's with my fat ugly ass to
begin with Jesus Christ both of you guys
[Music]
wow that close to the holidays
[Laughter]
am i a bad influence on you you never
mean like that that's [ __ ] hilarious
[Laughter]
people know but I'm nice they just you
know I have I have my people like me
have my moment so I can be a little hey
well this he's describing it this way I
couldn't resist myself sometimes two
negatives make a positive they give a
great looking kid yeah alright we got
into it the other night about it and now
she's saying she's not happy in her own
skin oh god she wants to be a dude and
if I truly loved her then I should
expect it I should accept it and get it
for her as a Christmas present said some
I was being a dick about dude [ __ ] this
chick this chick wants to get her nose
she's trying to trade up she's sick he a
fat ugly ass she wants you to buy some
[ __ ] save some of your cake money and
spend it on her [ __ ] tits are in a
nose right and I'll [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] said I haven't felt this
way about a girl in a long time I love
her the way she is and I don't want to
see her [ __ ] up her looks her body I
don't know what to do here Billy Boy any
advice would be appreciated from you and
lovely Nia yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] this I I
think you get out you're saying he
should break up with her get out no help
her with her self-esteem [ __ ] that what
you're just gonna give up on somebody
you love because they have a low
self-esteem and they're like freaking
out about it and no you know something I
was that was my advice until she said
you should buy me that for Christmas
you know [ __ ] expensive that is no no
no no is she watching reality TV she's
gonna try to get on Real Housewives the
[ __ ] Des Moines Iowa wherever the [ __ ]
you guys no she should really like if
she's really trying to do this it's her
body and it's her choice she should pay
for it if she really really wants to do
it she should save up her her pennies or
whatever it is save up like $100 a week
or whatever the [ __ ] it is cut out all
this
other stuff [ __ ] that she's doing
going out with friends going out with
you whatever the [ __ ] and she should
save up for it and just be like I don't
feel comfortable it was like paying for
you to alter your body that's something
not something that I you know believe in
that's not something I have the money
for it's like this is your body this is
your choice and I support you either way
no no and I support you either way
but I don't feel comfortable paying for
it that was the sound of a dump truck
backing up and the alley that you should
just drop her in I'm not doing this feel
comfortable I gotta be honest she's
perfectly well within your right to say
no to that and if she has a problem with
it then yeah I guess she can bounce and
she's gonna pass those low self-esteem
body issues under under your [ __ ]
kids it's gonna be a nightmare she needs
to go to therapy oh I don't know what
the [ __ ] she needs to do but if I was
you [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that you
think you need [ __ ] me and you need to
pay for it [ __ ] you I would come over
there I would dress up like Santa Claus
when I broke up with her get the [ __ ]
out of my life I'm spending all my money
on me and dude you need if you think
you're fat and ugly you can do something
about the fat and you can get a [ __ ]
personality so why don't you get all the
money she wants you to spend on tits Wow
what are you [ __ ] get a [ __ ]
training for yourself do two [ __ ]
move on from this train wreck give me a
buff Jesus Christ they'd almost ruined
my [ __ ] Thanksgiving oh no I'm just
kidding it anyways don't listen to me
I'm not trying to tell you to [ __ ]
break up with her but that that that's a
major like like what the [ __ ] did you
just say to me moment you know don't
text during the goddamn podcast what do
you have somebody over all right yeah
with you would be you know what I think
is a great name
Montt prog-rock I'm trying to pick a
stereotypical black name from way back
in the day there was nobody named Lamont
by the way except that guy on Sanford &
Son
boo-boo alright progressive rock Hey Oh
Billy Burford glad to hear you're
looking at a more progressive rock like
every genre of music 99% of it is
unimaginative trash and 1% is really
unique and well done yes I like your
perspective your percentage might be a
little harsh I'd like to think 10% at
least is good even the good stuff can be
off-putting at first it just takes some
time to digest like good scotch it might
be harsh to most people at first but if
you put the time and you'll find a lot
of interesting [ __ ] going on early
generous Genesis is some of my favorite
check out the tracks the musical box
watch did she wake up okay watcher of
the skies and dancing with the moonlit
night the compositions are complex and
beautiful and Phil calls Collins was
really a perfect drummer yeah he's one
of my favorite drummers of all time the
band also had some amazing tracks like
close to the edge heart of the sunrise
and gates of delirium Bill Bruford was
one of their first was on one of their
first few albums and was a beast all
right
you already mentioned King Crimson they
had some truly great song but always had
a few improvised stinkers on each album
check out 21st century schizoid man
larks tongues in aspect part 2 and
starless Bruford is drumming on two of
those tracks finally you got to get into
magma who was one of the who has one of
the best drummers to have walked the
earth I never heard of this guy
Christian Vander it's really his band he
composed all of the music and their
sound is totally unique they sing in an
alien language so you don't get
distracted by stupid lyrics well what
about their alien language that sounds
like something that sounds like a sketch
Will Ferrell would be in at almost 70
years old van
plays incredibly they are so good live
that I've flown to LA in London just to
see them play in the past couple years
I'll have to check this up look up live
videos of them playing the last seven
minutes and Zombies your drum teacher
will vouch for them Lahey's easy
I'm also psyched to hear you mention
Meshuga
oh yeah they've unbelievable they're
another one that takes a lot of time to
get a feel for but once you figure out
that almost all of their songs are in a
strange kind of 4/4 they become one of
the grooviest bands you've ever heard
and there's no coming back
enjoy your furry into the weirdness of
progressive music you speckled [ __ ]
speckled [ __ ] that said no one Sonjia
how was your Thanksgiving it was
delicious
I don't mean the meal I mean how was the
weekend oh it's great thank you
there you go guys that's what I come
home to what that's what I come home so
I was like great thank you and you said
yeah that's what I come home soon as if
I was some big negative Nelly no you
just sounded like I was asking if your
autograph as you rushed through an
airport great thank you
[Laughter]
it's just when you throw a roll of paper
towels at me that's what you should have
done I'm stopping get away from me get
away from me stop it get off of me I
will clean myself oh he's picking at me
you're a mother now go downstairs and go
[ __ ] pick at your daughter there
isn't she beautiful I know we had the
best day though we watched the end of
the Patriots game what's you know I
watched the whole Patriots game and uh
you know everybody's you know that's one
of the reasons why I don't get overly
excited about a nine and two record when
you're playing the Miami Dolphins which
is already
just a franchise that has been
transitioning trying to get to another
level for [ __ ] decades it feels feels
like and you know Jay Cutler isn't
playing it's just one of those games we
got like three four sacks which are
gonna Pat our numbers so then we go into
the playoffs oh they'll play they've got
a decent pass rush bubble up this like
teams like that will pad your [ __ ]
stats I gotta tell you that backup
quarterback was actually pretty good but
I just and I love in Tomica Suh I just I
don't feel he's a dirty player I just
think that that guy plays in the wrong
era he is he is a [ __ ] dick butkus
violent world of Sam Huff type of
football player he's just playing in the
Millennial age I love that guy anyways
so we watched that then I've started to
watch some of the Rams Saints game which
was a great game and then you know she
had the running nose and stuff so I was
constantly having to deal with that and
I don't know I read some books yeah she
loves that book I read that book to like
five times
really yeah she loves it you know
yeah but she gets the faces too that
they're making you know like like happy
face and you know and then the laughs
one I'll be like I go like you know I go
laughing I'm like Kiki look at me go
like she laughs - it's [ __ ] awesome
the big belly laughs like when you
really get her you know I got her
yesterday you know but then she does a
little he also ya know but I got the
belly blast yesterday when you were
still mad at me did you hard I was
making her laugh yes yeah about what
like completely you know being mad at
the wrong person because you were upset
about a game and like that film no it
really wasn't that what it was was I was
carrying Lola my ribs were killing me
and then because she didn't want to be
in the stroller
if she like has a moment where she's
like she'll be fine
you keep it moving and she's fine she's
not one of those kids she's not at that
stage yet where she just screaming for
ten minutes straight that's not who she
is and plus she has to learn that you
can't carry her all the time yeah but no
but she also rode all the way over there
in the car and then we walked up the
street we come back down the street she
was like I'm over it you know when they
strapped in like astronauts it
eventually it's like get this [ __ ]
thing off me I understand it's like yeah
I wouldn't like to I mean I'd like to be
wheeled around but after that time we
got stuck in the ride at Six Flags yeah
that's what they feel like
yeah like [ __ ] yeah I would think so
anyways alright sorry anyways that's the
podcast
Happy Thanksgiving post Thanksgiving
weekend to you what but what did you say
about being mad at that little boy what
did I say I don't know when I came in
you were saying you were just talking
about it I was then I was saying I I
said do this no I do that you're just
gonna make it done I realized I was
being a baby because I was embarrassed
with my behavior there is that enough
yeah and she's when she sat down she sat
down next to me afterwards I was
watching the late game and she's like is
this game gonna make you upset oh my god
the amount of times Nia I swear to God
that if you were a guy I would just
start swinging that was one of those
moments now I'm going to start swinging
I would have done that most guys do
acted like I was gonna swing and not
[Music]
bring it I'm not the one you know what I
am the one you can talk all this [ __ ]
you want to I'm an old man let's go bro
you want to do this bro you know what
[ __ ] frat boy white guys also do
they'll bite your ear off [ __ ]
lunatics especially if their dad's a
judge you had to depends on like what
[ __ ] yet yeah I I stayed out of that
world I did not like that world at all
that world
was [ __ ] right when I came the [ __ ]
that they used to do to people during
[ __ ] hazing the [ __ ] stories I'm
telling you the stories that [ __ ]
guys got from getting hazed dude it was
it was [ __ ] they really make it I'm
not talking about that I'm not talking
about that and II am we stuck a [ __ ]
carrot up his ass kid was screaming I
just remember that was one of my first
jokes in my stand-up back
yeah people go how we didn't join a frat
I was like I don't know cuz I kind of
got this thing about letting other guys
shove fruit up my ass and used to get a
laugh back in the 90s because everybody
oh it was like funny like oh hazing no
you don't die from that you did souls
crushed how about talking about them
making you drink all the water and all
that you know and eat all these pancakes
and then they die that's millennial [ __ ]
I'm talking about what the [ __ ] they
used to decent [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out
of you and [ __ ] a a scrapy with
[ __ ] nuts the stories I used to hear
the [ __ ] I used to [ __ ] hear that
people used to do to each other night
and I was just like I used to always
think that and then what then you gonna
hang out with them afterwards I'm not
saying that always [ __ ] happen but
dude some of this [ __ ] there's that one
Ivy League school with it this is some
puke pancake you have to [ __ ] eat and
somebody finally said something about it
and all these older people done he was a
Dartmouth or something they were all mad
like dude I can't believe it's gotten
all it's called no it's called the vom
'let because they're [ __ ] losers
because because because your cuz you're
exploiting somebody at a very weak
moment in their life they left their
parents they need new friends they want
to feel like and I always was just yeah
I draw yes oh yeah yeah yeah I would you
should hear the [ __ ] stories like
some of my relatives weren't France some
of this [ __ ] they did today
took him outside the dead a winner
sprayed him with like a fire hose cuz
somebody threw a bucket of paint on one
of the older brothers or whatever
sprayed him with bucket paint yeah
I've got like [ __ ] pneumonia almost
died they could just beat the [ __ ] out
of you it was bad it was bad then every
once in a while you heard the fruit that
I want to make it seem like everybody
did that by remembering at Gold's Gym
and this guy was sitting I think was
just talking about hazing people at
football camp and he was going like yeah
that we shoved a carrot up it says kid
was [ __ ] screaming no I don't want to
do that I'm not gonna do a [ __ ] me
too guy thing here alright I don't blame
the victims but I heard what happened
and I was just like yeah [ __ ] frets look
at my own friends yeah you're gonna you
know we're gonna rush a fret yeah I'll
think about it buddy yeah I couldn't get
through the [ __ ] army I can get
through the army yeah you did you did
what are you gonna do beat the [ __ ] out
of me then I don't have to go to war
I'll do that
ooh did I get a dishonorable discharge
I'm still [ __ ] here
I'll do that no I never would have made
no here's a deal at my age of it when I
was a young kid I would have done
whatever the [ __ ] they said if I was 18
19 I would have done whatever the [ __ ]
they said so that's why they do it but
you know anybody middle age yeah I'd be
like Michael J Fox in like yeah what are
we doing here Sarge all right that's it
all right
go [ __ ] yourself so I didn't where I am
in this podcast I'll talk to you guys on
Thursday right if you want to throw in
you [ __ ] hate your football hazing in
yeah I'm over all of that [ __ ] I
remember like faculty members going
talking about [ __ ] that they saw [ __ ]
older kids doing to other kids
and I don't want to hear it because it's
at this [ __ ] time because what you're
gonna do is they're creating this is how
they everybody's looking at like
Hollywood right now like it's this giant
non-consent consensual like [ __ ] orgy
and it isn't most people out here
busting their ass to [ __ ] great
people and all that but then now they're
gonna say that everybody's are you know
[ __ ] suck a dick you're not gonna get
a [ __ ] commercial it's like that no
and if they all have to go down I don't
give a [ __ ] because I'm a white chick in
my 20s all right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll
check in on you on Thursday